cinéma avec la sortie attendit de la
légende de zorro antonio banderas se
glisse une nouvelle fois sous les traits
du justicier masqué et comme il ya sept
ans il retrouve la superbe catherine
zeta jones tous deux sont les invités de
ce journal cette fresque d'aventuré
d'amour et d'action ne manque ni
d'humour ni de panache c'est leur donne
de nouvelles couleurs aux films de cape
et d'épée parce qu'elle deschamps ça ne
se voit pas mais zorro et son cheval
tornado en 86 ans a paru dans un roman
en 1919 le fléau de capistrano le
justicier masqué a tout de suite séduit
hollywood en 1920 douglas fairbanks et
le premier or au cinéma suivi 20 ans
plus tard de tyrone power
en tout 35 acteurs leur ont incarné dans
plus de 40 films et de séries tournée
dans six pays
on trouve de tout dans la vie 2 auront
des chansons parodiques des aventures
érotiques et un zorro gay la grande
euros cela faisait un quart de siècle
que les blues n'avaient pas raconter ses
aventures lorsque antonio banderas en
dos à son tour la panoplie sans doute la
plus offerte aux petits garçons à noël
c'est le premier acteurs hispaniques a
joué zorro aux états unis dans le nouvel
opus il peut compter sur l'aide de sa
femme
car pour faire durer un genre il faut
aussi parfois le renouveler
on a tous été élevés avec zorro moi je
finis au pays de galles et je me
souviens du feuilleton ou noir et blanc
c'était le samedi matin
vous savez il fait partie de notre
subconscient on connaît tous zorro mais
perdre on m'attend à rebours n'est pas
celui que tu penses tu ne sais pas ce
que je pense qu'yves moi je pense savoir
ce que tu penses que si l'on veut bien
oublier que le méchant du film et un
français ça devient la mode à hollywood
on passera un bon moment ça vous rend
ces nouvelles aventures plus drôle plus
enlevée mais fidèle à la tradition que
j'ai dit que nous n'étions pas c'est la
pointe nous voilà enfin d'accord sur un
point
là